Vamos a resolver algunos problemas de porcentajes,
y de hecho pues vamos a entrarle de una vez,
¿cuánto es...?
déjame escribirlo por aquí...
¿Cuánto es el... me voy a tomar el 15% de 40?
el 15% de 40...
Y bueno, espero que tú ya sepas que nosotros
podemos convertir este porcentaje en decimal
simple y sencillamente dividiendo 15 entre 100
y si yo a esto lo multiplico por 40, ya
voy a obtener el 15% de 40, entonces, el 15%
lo podemos ver en su forma decimal como .15,
es decir, 15/100 y si yo lo que quiero tomarme
es el 15% de 40, entonces tengo que
multiplicar a 40 por .15
¿Y cuánto es esto?
5 por 0 es 0, 5 por 4 es 20,
después hay que poner un 0 aquí abajo y me queda,
1 por 0 es 0 y 1 por 4 es 4 y ahora hay que realizar
la respectiva suma y si 2 y 4 son 6,
0 y 0 y no olvides recorrer el punto, tenemos que
recorrer el punto dos lugares y entonces me
va a quedar justo aquí el punto decimal y el 6.00.
Es decir que el 15% de 40 es 6 y espero
no confundirte bastante,
porque este es un problema
bastante sencillo, el 15% de 40 es 6 y ya
con esto vámonos al siguiente problema,
en el cual espero que te confunda un poco más
porque la idea de este video es que te sientas
un poco confundido con porcentajes y veas
cómo podemos resolver estos problemas.
¿Cuál es el .2%, el .2% de 7?
Y bueno, aquí hay que tener cuidado...
el .2% de 7...
porque si tú lo piensas en un inicio y dices,
"¡ah! pues si yo el .2 por ciento lo veo
en su forma decimal y su forma decimal es ".2"
estás equivocado.
Ya desde ahí tendrías mal la respuesta porque
te estarías olvidando de dividir entre 100,
recuerda que sea cual sea la cantidad que
tenemos en el porcentaje hay que dividirla
entre 100.
En este caso me quedaría .2 entre 100 o si
multiplicamos por 10, tanto arriba como abajo,
me quedaría 2 entre 1000.
Ésta es una forma de ver este porcentaje,
si vemos .2% en su forma decimal
esto es 2 sobre 1000 o hay otra forma mucho
más sencilla de verlo.
Lo que hay que hacer es recorrer el punto decimal,
si partimos del .2%, entonces hay que recorrer el punto decimal dos unidades hacia la izquierda
y voy a obtener .002,
esta es su forma decimal y esto es muy importante,
sirve para cualquier porcentaje, tú te paras
en donde está el punto decimal y recorres
el punto decimal dos unidades hacia la izquierda
y con esto obtienes su valor decimal.
No te vayas a ir con la finta de poner su valor decimal tal cual, porque entonces cometerías un error.
¡Muy bien! entonces ya tengo que quiero sacar
el .2% de 7 y para esto hay que multiplicar
a 7 por .002, así que vamos a hacerlo.
.002...
.0002 y a esto hay que multiplicarlo por 7
y bueno, esto está muy sencillo,
7 por 2 = 14, entonces voy a poner el 14 aquí
y después lo que hay que hacer es recorrer el punto
decimal tres lugares hacia la izquierda,
donde está el punto decimal de 14, hay que recorrerlo
tres lugares hacia la izquierda, entonces
ya tengo aquí el 14 y 1, 2, 3 y llego al .014.
Entonces, ya tengo la respuesta, el .2% de
7 es .014 y seguramente me vas a decir,
"oye pero es una cantidad bastante pequeña, ¿estaremos bien?"
Y la respuesta es que sí, tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo, .2% es mucho menor que
1%, imagínate que cuando yo tomo el 1% de 7,
lo que estoy haciendo es dividir a 7 en 100 partes
y si yo quiero el .2% de 7 me tengo
que tomar una parte mucho más pequeña,
de hecho, es como dividir el 7 en 500 partes
y tomarme solamente 1 de estas 500 partes.
El .2% es exactamente lo mismo que 1/500,
1/500 por 7, pues es una cantidad muy pequeña,
pero bueno, espero que este ejercicio te haya
confundido lo suficiente porque vamos a ver
otro ejercicio donde espero que te confundas
aun más.
Recuerda que muchas veces cuando nos confundimos,
podemos matar las dudas.
Así que fíjate muy bien en éste.
¿4 es el 20% de qué número?
Y seguramente tú puedes decir, bueno,
voy a tomarme el 20% en su forma decimal que es
.20 y multiplicarlo por 4 y ya está,
pero estarías cometiendo un error.
Si tú multiplicas a 4 por .20 lo que estarías
haciendo es sacando el 20% de 4 y no es lo
que queremos, fíjate bien lo que dice la pregunta
¿4 es el 20% de qué número?
Así que lo que vamos a hacer es fijarnos
en este número y por eso voy a llamar "x"
a este número al número que queremos encontrar,
sea"x" el número , si yo sé que 4 es el
20% de este número, eso quiere decir que
20% de "x" es igual a 4, porque recuerda que
"x" es el número que estamos buscando.
Y seguramente ya se te prendió el foco y
dices ¡wow! esto ya lo reconozco,
esto lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera visto en
su forma decimal, .20 ó .2, fíjate que .20
y .2 es lo mismo, .2 por "x"
esto tiene que ser igual a 4.
Recuerda que si yo tengo un número y le quiero
sacar el 20% lo multiplico por .20
y ya sé que esto me tiene que dar 4.
¿Qué número es este?
¿Y qué crees?
Ya tenemos una ecuación lineal bien sencilla
de resolver, para despejar a "x" lo que hay
que hacer es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre .2, esto entre .2, esto entre .2, estos
dos se van, desaparecen, porque .2 y .2 es 1,
solamente me queda "x" y entonces obtengo
que "x" es igual a 4 entre .2
¿Y cuánto es esto?
.2 entre 4, aquí está el punto decimal de 4 y bueno,
lo estoy poniendo porque voy a
recorrer el punto decimal una vez hacia la derecha,
tanto adentro como afuera,
para que así pueda quitar el punto decimal
que me estorba aquí afuera de mi división.
Y me queda 2 entre 40, 4 entre .2 es exactamente lo mismo que 40 entre 2
y bueno, esta división es muy sencilla,
¿40 cuántas veces cabe en 2?
Bueno, si esto lo hago es 2 y después 0,
es decir, 20 veces, 40 entre 2 es 20 ó 20
por 2 es igual a 40, por lo tanto "x" es igual a 20.
Y tiene toda la lógica del mundo,
¿4 es el 20% de qué número?
El número es 20, ¿por qué?
Porque si yo me fijo en el 20%, el 20% es
como dividir 20 entre 5, tomarme un 20% es
tomarme una quinta parte de esta cantidad y la quinta parte de 20 es 4, 4 por 5 es 20,
pero si de todas maneras no te queda claro
o no me crees, lo puedes hacer por ti mismo,
puedes agarrar el 20% de 20, es decir,
.2 por 20 y vas a ver que te va a dar de respuesta 4,
.2 por 20 esto es igual a 4.
Bueno, deberías intentarlo para ver que en efecto llegamos a la misma respuesta.
Ahora bien, déjame hacer otro ejercicio,
el último ejercicio de este video.
Vamos a hacer un ejercicio muy parecido
al que hicimos hace rato.
3 es el 9%... voy a decir que 3 es el 9% ¿de qué número?
¿de qué número?
Y bueno de igual manera que hicimos en el
ejercicio pasado voy a definir a "x",
como el número el cual cumple que 3 es su 9%...
cumple que 3 es su 9%...
bueno, de hecho no tuve que haber escrito
todo esto, pero ya tengo el valor de "x"
y como le hicimos la vez pasada.
Dijimos .09 es decir, el 9% de "x",
esto sabemos que es igual a 3 y voy a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre .09 y me queda que "x"
es igual a 3 entre .09, ¿y cuánto es esto?
Pues vamos a hacerlo.
.09 va a dividir a 3, aquí voy a poner un
punto decimal y varios 0 y voy a recorrer
el punto decimal dos veces hacia la derecha,
1, 2... 1, 2... perfecto, aquí está mi punto decimal.
Es decir que 3 entre .09 es lo mismo que 300 entre 9
¿y 300 entre 9 pues cuánto es?
30 entre 9 es 3, 3 por 9 = 27 y sobran 3,
ya viste el patrón, bajamos el 0, 3 otra vez,
3 por 9 = 27 y sobran 3, otra vez 3,
otra vez 3, otra vez 3, otra vez 3,
así hasta el infinito, es decir que la respuesta es,
33.333333 ó 33.3 periódico, 3 es el 9% de
33.3 periódico o también lo podemos ver
en su forma de fracción, 33 enteros 1/3,
porque recuerda que 1/3 es lo mismo que .33333333333.
Ambas son respuestas correctas, ambas respuestas
están bien y de hecho con bastante precisión.
No en todos los ejercicios tienes que tener
la mejor precisión,
aunque en este ejercicio nos resultó que teníamos bastante buena precisión.
Y bueno, lo importante de todos estos ejercicios
que estoy haciendo,
es que te des cuenta que hay una gran diferencia dependiendo de lo que te diga el problema,
el problema puede decir dos cosas distintas,
si te piden el 10% de 100,
pues eso es muy fácil,
solamente hay que multiplicar 100 por .10,
pero recuerda que si te dicen el problema contrario,
es decir, 100 es el 10% de qué cantidad,
bueno, pues en ese momento hay que
aplicar las matemáticas
y hay que hacer el álgebra
y te va a dar de resultado 1000.
Espero no te confundas bastante,
vamos a intentar hacer más ejercicios de esto
para que lo entiendas perfectamente.